what's happening there reject nation we
are going to watch episode 9 season 2 of
super matter lois today little heads up
there is a couple of fans on right now
because apparently uh if we turn on the
ac all the power in here dies out sort
of a couple days behind on some stuff
and they're also doing massive
construction outside
so we can't open the window either sorry
for the extra noise in the background i
love living here i hope my landlord is
watching
anyhoo full of
stick
foreign rejects but if you can't follow
us over there please be sure to leave a
like and a comment down below helps out
with the videos engagement process
then boys at prepper thanks for helping
us out let's get to this
[Music]
i knew lucy would come through we fixed
that thing suit too but we need to hurry
we don't have much time come on ally you
can do it i believe in you
change sides lucy said you were the only
one who could get across
you'll find anderson right you'll save
him
soon i'll be able to save everyone
all going according to plan
that's cool
smart he's in bizarro's old suit hmm
she made it to the other side then i'll
bring her back
not even you can make it through
not in that
you just in my suit
oh what would you go for
buddy
reverse time just right here what's the
plan here
bizarro you look better
you got cleaned up
healed all your scars look like a
cryptic
you're
bee
get the crippled bean anymore
the world is wondering once again where
is superman this is yet another
catastrophic event in the past week
where the world's hero has failed to
appear we're superman take care of all
our [ __ ] problems
yeah come on
get mad at him when it's time to get mad
at him for not taking care of her
whoa
captain america we need to be focused on
strengthening our family values and in
smallville family should include
everyone not just your top donors
[Applause]
that's right
[Music]
buddy
not bad man you're a real hero steal
now you have to marry him lana
one month it's lois
lois lane
you know
[Laughter]
at least four letter l names
you fix carb can't make waffles
i'm sure let me food at the rally we can
just grab something over there no no no
just try another batch
we're gonna be late let me just wash it
real quick and we'll head over
dad these waffles are more than just
waffles i made them for you
you saw my poor attempt at thanking
everyone which is why i was wondering if
you'd take a look at my speech you
should be ashamed of yourself
i thought lois was saying that for a
second
we're getting the football season
cancelled my son is a senior this isn't
the time barb or the tone yeah you know
what i think uh i think i'll just go
door to door
should have slapped barb keep my son's
name
[Laughter]
hello i'm i'm so sorry uh
i gotta go
you better have a cool mask lined up
this is getting out of control don't let
kyle die captain we need to back up go
get the other horse
attack the delta side i got this
if i watched about this she might take
me back
you think your mom will take down dean
i hope so
she deserves to win
yes
nat i swear to god you interfere with
this [ __ ]
that misspeak earlier was a prediction
ouch
oh
come but i have no memory cheating on
you
what happened to our family
rise up jordan
[Music]
come on man soon you'll fly don't worry
you need to get out of here go
now
i'm happy for
hey natalie
are you feeling any better did you not
see my dad blatantly flirting with your
married mom i'm sorry that was rude i
just
today's the day my mom died
oh
oh then that is kind of funny
maybe he's just
dealing with it differently you know i
spent an hour this morning trying to
recreate her homemade waffle recipe and
he didn't even notice
the waffles did read books
[Laughter]
what else aren't you telling us
hello
yes this is lana cushing
dad
it looks like mark ruffalo there i know
thank you sweetie i am so sorry emily is
freaking out i really do have to go hey
you should go why don't you come with us
uh i'm just gonna stop by the apartment
first you know and uh get myself cleaned
up okay
it was this crazy fire and i had to save
mr cushing and i got cornered so
i flew
what did fly just took a really strong
leap yeah
building in a single bound today's the
day that's mom died
and i completely forgot
she's have reason to hate me right now
you should probably try to talk to her
oh wait oh i was telling you
maybe you can go there pretend to be
your mom
so my granddad's been training me he has
been what oh no
oh well i don't need your permission
under my roof yes you do
not when i'm the one with superpowers oh
[ __ ]
badger to confess
jordan's best scene ever that's right
how could you
and don't tell me you were too busy i
guess i just wanted to forget that day
that's not okay you don't get to just
eternally sunshine mom's memory
no seriously i understood that reference
yeah i want to
be able to enjoy this life we have to
get this life we have it's because of
her
you know i don't want a dad who would
ever forget that
team net
finally brought us around
now there's a gray area there
but i'm going to choose a side team now
it's an assembly required
yeah um that's a wobble head there's
gotta be people over
dad you're bleeding um
it's fine it's
never mind there's no woman it's just
christ
it's just the
remnants of his dignity
i feel like he would have like
friends at work who could help him
acquaintances of any kind
i have two teenage boys who think they
are grown men i might have a better idea
than you think
i'm not gonna be a single parent forever
clark's coming back you started the show
we got season three
this is a big operation it is dangerous
and people are gonna get hurt kyle
cushing almost died we need to put an
end to this and they don't know the kind
of drug they're dealing with sweetie
it's never too late to do the right
thing i love his hair i know and you
promise you'll protect them with the
entire might of the dod
yeah i'll make a call rod
get out of here
he made his choices and now he needs to
live with them mom if
he could it's not your responsibility
your dad's just gonna have to take care
of himself
okay
yeah
god everyone just blow it off no
bad day to be sarah
promise to keep them anonymous right
that's right
they won't get in trouble
you have my word i'll bring her in
her
girl steal jason
hello candace
i want to play a game
[Laughter]
his name's mickey where does mickey get
his supply i tell you and the people he
works for find out i've done this before
i always protect my sources it's true
plus our granddad here pretty much runs
the dod he'll make sure nothing bad
happens as long as you cooperate i've
had jordans that don't speak again
listen you really want to talk to this
guy
a place on old mcclellan road i think we
can work with that
that'll be all for now we'll walk her
home again this is such a good show damn
if we just drive down alma collin road
not gonna happen you have played hero
enough for one day it's not a bad idea
fine but you are to stay in the car
until we get back to this house
understood
such great rhythm to this episode man
it's like [ __ ] birdman
she deserved better i know that
but so do you
someone who needs to remind that boy
that he is lucky to be dating my
daughter
i want to go kick his ass why is this
show super said i'm putting jordan down
in the situation
that's the weight of a secret identity i
guess
i hope that you love us as much as we
love you
because you're gonna be stuck with us
for a very long time
i love you
man
that is rough
gotta make sure the goose is in the
gander before he's entered the team does
that even mean it means stay in the car
mom there's guys in there it doesn't
matter that was the deal i am choosing
to trust you on this don't make me
regret it
oh no
no don't leave him in the car
that's what i'm talking about let's go
dad there's a whole operation in here we
don't need that let's go
all right we gotta call it in that's not
happening
oh
thank god josh it's in the car
what if i don't win
by the way you're a total rock star all
of these people came out here to support
you
but a loser's a loser man
they're going to be really pissed if you
don't win
the election board's about to announce a
winner
i would not want to be with the crowd of
people no i think this could be a
private place what do you think i think
she's gonna win i think she's gonna win
what are you doing what's it look like
these are fireman chair knots the harder
you struggle the tighter it gets
it was a hobble knot maybe you could
wiggle out but not this how many times
you've been tied up
better you don't know
we need to activate jordan
what activate jordan
dad i've seen what jordan can do and
it's more than enough to get us out of
here surrounded by xk though yeah
jordan honey if you can hear me we need
your help right now
so you need to be very
very careful
oh yeah dad the southern most part of
the warehouse there are at least two
added inside and one of them is heading
our way dad jordan we need your help
shatter his whole body
wow
oh no
oh [ __ ] he fast yeah
that's so cool
that was so awesome oh
quite satisfying
[Music]
jordan activated
george we can see your face
okay
thank you
um
how close was it
57
43 okay
[ __ ] yeah full of [ __ ] you'd collect an
ass [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm happy for her
[Applause]
[Music]
i would have double down on the fake out
[ __ ] are you serious
no no
i'm leaving my husband
leaving smallville together
looks like lana won
i'm gonna go find sarah
yeah great this was an important day for
me and i wanted to share it with you
i know
i have things i want to tell you but i
can't
oh
you should take this are you are you
breaking up with me
yeah
i think i am remember when you stayed
with her when she cheated on him
that's right
but
it's not safe
i broke up with jordan
you did what you had to do
for a reason i say tonight you and me we
load up on chilaquiles
tomorrow we'll uh
we'll figure out what comes next a life
of denial i'm gonna take your sister in
the middle of the night we're gonna get
the hell out of it
start a whole new life
i don't know maybe focus on us
yeah
i'd like that
will you marry me
john what is it
weird headache i think from staring the
laptop all week so online school is no
joke you know you should go home
i'm two blocks away
no
no
no but i do want you to know how proud i
am
of the hero you are becoming
hey look
john's home
whoa
no it's from the other side that's not
her jonathan
where's clark
stewie
he was too late
oh no
oh no
clark
wow
[Music]
cheers up
[Laughter]
try harder jesus
he's like no son of mine
no way no
no i'm a reporter
it's my job
that is not trying to do this it's silly
it's like seconds later
oh it's so funny
and uh
yeah i started getting the headache i
was like oh you must be
not speak
yeah
she could give two shits to talk about
jordan's heart or a pretty pretty
competitor
but thanks for saving my life
shifts conversations i know you're
feeling you're gonna feel it babe
i know you're going through the most
emotional pain possible for a teenager
but
a damn man no
that's still a that was a great episode
terrific yeah that was terrific man it
was kind of like if uh
hold on give me a second i'll get it
it's like if mark webb
and paul thomas anderson
had a
child that
was venturing into directing and started
off with television
okay
that's what i like in this episode too
yeah
had some of that like uh romantic and
not romantic but that like you know
coming of age dramatic some of those
superheroisms it also kind of moved a
little bit like a play
at times that had this like really
strong building dynamic rhythm as it was
cut in between the stories and what it
ultimately escalated to
starts off on a very like downward note
and then
like everything flips whatever was
potentially positive
turns downward it looked like it really
like
seemed like hopeful and then remained
positive was a lot of winning mater but
all the other things just kept like
completely flipped and i love that yeah
because this season's about mirroring
it's like the shadow side yeah situation
yeah yeah i love though i think the
jordan storyline was so well flushed out
yes that was so well done like when he
was rebelling against lois was
what is that actress's name god damn it
who plays lois yeah elizabeth tullock
i don't know what we're talking about
betsy bitsy tulik
no
it's lois actress
my bad
yeah so uh her performance
is so strong again you know like clark's
not even in this episode he's in it he
makes a cameo if anything he's at the
bookends of it and they i didn't even
miss him
ha who did i piss off
it's not that i don't me not like oh my
god he's not here it was that everyone
is so good yeah the episode suffered
none for his abs and it the writing is
so strong
and they i like how there was that
that looming a lot of the times when
they do some [ __ ] like that in a show
my mind eventually gets to the point of
like
jesus christ where is he come on yeah we
know he's coming back let's get him in
here you know let's let's get it going
okay and then without him being in here
other than like the prologue and and the
the epilogue for this one episode
i didn't find myself like going man this
show right now really needs some of
tyler's presence he everyone is so good
and the writing is was so strong like
every storyline was so well done in the
conclusion it led to because of its
really tense taught
like really well executed calculated
direction and the editing was it's like
just so rock solid
and that i i was really impressed with
this one you know especially when you
take out your title lead superhero
character and you manage to do a story
about a father and a daughter and then
what that grief is like and then the
story of a person who's on the verge of
a breakup and having to deal with her
parents being separated and
a son with powers and then the
confrontation finally revealing the
person you've kept secretly like there's
so many
other moving pieces that all just
just formed so well this great meld
that
like had surprising turns by the end of
it like really good arcs so i i don't
know i wonder if the writers were like
clark's not going to be in this episode
so we're going to make sure this is the
best and it also elevates the stakes for
the positions that are in oh yeah 100
and they did nicely to make clark's
absence
apparent and and make that it's weird
it's like he is gone but you still feel
the his presence or lack thereof
throughout and the effect that that has
on the situations and i feel like
everything with jordan really nicely
balances out both that tension as well
as that catharsis on jordan's behalf and
and i think they did really nicely yeah
to
juxtapose these developments to where
you're right rooting for jordan you want
him to go out there and you know really
come into his own
and make a difference and you know you
want that validation for him you want
that you know gap to be filled for
superman obviously but then yeah you
have that sort of personal cost and
that's another thing where they've had
the debate before and you're like come
on just tell her but you know the
further we get the more it's like yeah
it'll probably still be a bad idea
at least right now but even then just a
terrible idea sorry to cut you off after
me monologuing for three minutes just
want to say sure
i'm so glad he did not tell her yeah it
would be awful yeah it's a that would be
a disaster i think in a lot of ways not
that i don't even necessarily trust
sarah but especially at the timing of
this it would just not be the
the right thing to do
and uh yeah they just they did really
well to draw like oh
they have a bunch of plot lines that
could easily feel rote and annoying or
whatever and i i even saw sappy yeah or
sappy and i even saw some people in the
comments being like come on hurry it up
with the whole jonathan thing but i
thought that was really well timed out
and to have that come to a head here and
you know to have him
dealing like even his like struggle with
just the people of the town being like
hey
you took away our football season you're
still a pariah and so for him to at
least get that weight lifted you know
they're like there's a lot of really
subtle catharsis in this that happens
through painful
you know developments or painful action
to get to that catharsis and so yeah
like i think they
they really have such a strong wonderful
grip on just the character themes and
where to place each of those moments
throughout the episodes so that it
doesn't feel like you've stepped away
for anybody too long and nobody feels
like an afterthought when you do catch
back in with them
uh yeah like this is one of the best
episodes i think so far
and you know out of many great episodes
yeah everyone was really strong
like i i think they really layered
as i take it this whole thing with like
sarah
uh i i still really love the actress and
i i still like the characters a lot too
like i i understand her yeah and
her
like just how everything just feels like
it's closing in on her and she's being
shut out left and right and she just
wants connection right now
and
like the way it led to her
to go from being mad at her dad to
now staying at his place that
progression made a lot of sense like you
can see he's trying his best
and she still loves him and she's in
this whole situation you know like lana
in the midst of all the this chaotic
election that she has to deal with she
has to
you know she
lana's gonna be a little bit
i don't wanna say dismissive but quick
you know yeah she's gonna be decisive
about where that you know takes priority
in her life right now yeah and
and so yeah like i think that's uh yeah
and the election storyline is good story
that's it so yeah like her
her progression sometimes i do think the
show is like
a little bit
it just doesn't just seem to just feel
like they really dropped the whole
cheating thing
i'm sarah
in a way they're just so abrupt
it like seemed like it skipped in that
same episode or the next one it just
skipped two
jordan doesn't deserve you and it just
seems like it's been riding that line
ever since
and that's just what i i find it funny
now i'm not mad at the show it's just
it's funny to me because
it was so fast when that happened when
lana's in that garage being like if he
doesn't want you back he doesn't deserve
you
too now here have been like hey he
doesn't deserve him like [ __ ] give
him some give him a couple minutes would
you
like really this is the first time you
seem like you're really trying to talk
to him you want to be like prior to
number one right now come on
fair fair what's the weight of of a kiss
versus a whole lot of absence and
important moments yeah but she's that
was the first time she seemed like she
really tried talking to him about it
that was true yeah that's true
yeah we'll see maybe there i mean
there's got to be further development of
that down the line maybe the cheating
storyline will rear its ugly head back
or something or maybe she'll go hey this
whole experience my dad has taught me
something or maybe she might have been
like i cheated and then i wanted you to
meet that girl is that why you've been
absent lately have i been pushing you
away
that might have been a more believable
layer um good call you should write for
the show dude if it's about
relationships i mean god
i got this
metropolis got this
smallville love you know what teenage
cheating is like
you gotta understand when you're
teenagers
if you kiss someone that is like they
had sex with that person all right
like the weight of them i'm taking my 30
year old self
of course i'm like no it's not the same
weight i'd still be like living and be
like [ __ ] you i'm not doing anything
with you anymore like you're done like i
would still be that person
however like the weight when you're a
teenager
that's what it feels like you know it
feels like your world is ending yeah and
this is the greatest betrayal you could
imagine yeah so yeah
i just think that there's a little more
fleshing out that they could have done
and i know i know for a fact i am not
the only one who thinks of who
does not think like uh you don't trust
me you know the end of that sentence
there's a definition yeah yeah
um so yeah it's just funny now yeah and
uh mark ruffalo is good in the show
photographer's great yeah
the gnat i thought she was gonna get on
my nerves again because sometimes she
could be a little one the symptoms her
like
resentful attitude seems to lose all
layers and if she the actor sometimes
feels in those moments only plays
that would like
that emotion
you know what i mean it sometimes it
feels like
it's like a comparison like with lana i
know lana with lois
when
she's
like upset
with
jordan
there's so many layers she's not just
playing that one note of upset you know
you could feel that she's concerned
she's worried she loves him that's why
she's angry at him because she fears for
his life like there's so many different
emotions where sometimes i feel like the
direction for her is
just be upset
yeah yeah
it's like when you see to ride that
example yeah it's like when lois is
reprimanding john versus jordan there is
a difference in dimension whereas it
feels like we keep kind of
slipping back and forth with nat in this
story of like oh it looks like she's
making some headway oh no there's
something else that that is legitimately
emotionally distressing but then also
yeah it kind of brings us back to this
dynamic kind of in a what feels sort of
like a circular pattern so it would be
nice to see her
uh
give in or or achieving some sort of
personal
you know
validation or strength or something to
yeah temper that character so that it's
not just my entire experience on this
earth has just been kind of confronting
you know people not acknowledging my
past traumas well i don't know if it's
the direction that they give the actress
or if it's the actress herself in those
certain scenes
where some of that additional layer or
life underneath the
because on with
men or anger there's a bunch of other
emotions that follow it yeah that lead
to that's the story that leads to it
yeah and some and i think some of that
loses it's like that gets lost a little
bit
what i'm like i i obviously can
like like my point being is that in the
writing i think it's there you know when
she is
really upset with her dad about what's
happening that day
like i completely get that like that is
a hundred percent valid and
totally
like yeah like you have every right to
be upset i'd be upset too
it's just that
her performance of her being upset
didn't seem all that different to me
versus all the other times you've seen
her upset yeah and i'm like okay there's
a different layer here yeah it's a
different element of hurt it's a
different kind of taken aback quality
yeah that you would imagine
compared to the other situation she'd
been in not to disregard plenty of her
other scenes that i do think are
actually are genuinely really good i
think her her final scene was really
good too
and uh her
her confrontation with her first one
though uh not her first one i'm out of
her first or she really laid into him
when they got back home about how
i'm not gonna be with someone who's
gonna forget mom i don't want to be
around this and like we're the only two
people who remember her i thought her
performance there was really great
absolutely so
yeah i think like i thought this was her
best performance
so far and i think that scene was uh the
way they handled that was really strong
wish we kind of had a little more time
with it like john henriette's had a
moment for like a real matthew
mcconaughey moment there looking at that
footage
reacting crying yeah
yeah absolutely beats
[ __ ] watching a character react to
footage yeah
that's more cathartic yeah absolutely
maybe the next one i relate the most to
it
next episode just trapped on henry you
know in a room with a wall of tv because
all with old family footage just yeah
yeah yeah
and it made me jordan's rise to power is
a bad faster jordans
yeah i mean as bumped as i am for him he
had a really badass episode overall
when he discovered this that discovery
of the powers it's cool that you know we
get your first superman show we don't
really need to
do all the discovery of powers with him
with superman uh but you can do that
with his son and really do that slowly
over time
over the course of two seasons to get to
this point that it feels so
cathartic it feels it does feel
genuinely rewarding because
i i i wasn't that's like i'm sure that i
had a feeling to be fine obviously when
they were like
uh activate jordan
there was that part of me of
really still get his ass kicked though
i know there's other people yeah
with xk he's not that experienced out
here i know he's determined but he's
still getting his ass kicked man
this [ __ ] can't go sideways for him yeah
absolutely but hey man
sam lane taught him well yeah family
knows what he's doing that super speed
moment was really awesome that would
handle that yeah
and the way the sound goes out like that
was that was such a lovely moment it was
awesome when he froze him and then
punched him i thought it was good i
thought he shattered that guy's body
because i know they did that in episode
three
of uh
i think it was episode three of season
one
when he like when when superman uppercut
of that guy in the hotel room yeah and
he throws them in the ice first
but that guy had superpowers too i
believe yeah so
uh yeah i thought in that moment because
they didn't establish that the guy with
the gun had powers
because he has a gun if he was hopped up
he wouldn't he wouldn't need the gun
goddamn i'm gonna kill you in a way
you're familiar with this
that's just to respect your species or
maybe if they were like oh if we laser
it can lead to clues that's like you
know true they probably just get rid of
the body right i feel like yeah they
just shoot him and then burn up the body
so that way no one can find traces of
the body yeah so really fast
yeah
you know these aren't the brightest uh
drug cooking criminals
really could cut it up into pieces and
then spread the body parts all over the
city so that way you can't really tell
the time of death and whose body it is
and you gotta put it together there's
ways to get away with the crime that i
really think they could have done
much faster and they've got chemicals
all over this place are they going to
find something to dissolve their bodies
there's so many things they could have
done that were not all right i'll go up
there and shoot them why there's no
point yeah why did that guy with the
heat vision do it himself
why did he even bring him in and tie
them up in the first place he could have
just lasered them out front
i mean that's what they brought him in
to make sure like okay is the right
decision to kill them which i get
watching the guy with a gun so that's
why that's why you would make a better
criminal i'd make it greater than i
would that would just be like laser by
the spot
figure it out later guys
oh you got make sure it's the right call
and when you laser them place them into
pieces if you can't fully
um obliterate like every remnant you
know
and then you you spread the body parts
i'm glad you thought this out
yeah and then what you can do is
sometimes you can do is like probably
refrigerate the body parts to really
make it really confusing the time of day
but they have the ability to freeze
breath yes and then you just freeze the
body freeze the bodies let them thaw out
you know
get some like water logging going on
yeah yeah and then laser them then
probably get some steam reaction make it
even harder to tell whose body and how
same there's a lot of ways they could
have gotten rid of that body dude
spin-off show about a kryptonian serial
killer
of a guy always getting away
winning
all over the world new secret identities
always
i think we got a hit on our hands yeah
no conflict for
the evil protagonists we're following
who does this show emboldening
who does this speak to
oh
anyway that's the problem with dark
superman portrayals they always make
them be like ballistic ass dumbasses
like ah man you gotta take like a dexter
approach you gotta take a cunning evil
superman yeah
find your victim
[Laughter]
really
[Music]
hey i mean any writer's room dealing
with crime then by that uh token is is
full of sickos so amen are we really
that different all right guys well we're
done i think we nailed all the best
points that stuck around for this park
points guys leave your thoughts down
below check us out patreon thanks for
being here we'll catch you soon oh
wait let's shout out some patrons and
[ __ ] we love them
peter pachecos uses geico oh we joanna
saint louis
roe cree faster than bruce lee sumptuous
jambalaya 94. justin martin pop tartan
in the morning we'll fartin don't dare
haiti on rosie baby darth yoda order 66
quit the stalin i know we've all fallen
for colin philip to the brim j smith jr
jen smith subject of john smith that's
right don't tell on me melanie leblanc
natalie doran we met in person
once we love you forever
it's never drastic
jason dolan your pledge used to be
higher
all right guys well thank you so much
for watching to our patreon page each of
you thank you helping us have a
successful march over there we will see
you guys next month at least a third of
you
[Music]